Have you heard of Bizarro World?
In the late 1960’s DC comics introduced
the idea of a Bizarro World, a world that
is opposite of our daily expectations.
As fans watch their favorite films they speculate
on alternate versions of the plots, characters
or even the worlds these characters live.
These conjectures can create some weird theories
that can change the way you look at some of
your favorite films, especially when they
are a cherished kids film.
Make sure to hit that subscribe button and
like this video as we introduce you to Screen
Rant’s list of ten Theories That Turn Kids
Movies into Creepy Movies.
Frozen, Tangled and The Little Mermaid
We know that Rapunzel and Flynn were at Elsa's
coronation because we spotted them."
We know that the coronation takes place three
years after the death of Elsa and Anna’s
parents.
We also know that the films Tangled and Frozen
were released three years apart.
From the architecture in Tangled we can say
the movie takes place in Germany and the architecture
in Frozen puts us in Norway.
Did the Frozen parents travel to Germany for
Rapunzel and Flynn’s wedding but their ship
sank on the way there?
And in between Germany and Norway is Denmark,
which is home to a famous mermaid.
Is the sunken ship that Ariel visits under
the sea the vessel of Elsa and Anna’s parents?
Mind blown!
The Rugrats Movie
The Rugrats Movie is based off the popular
Nickelodeon children’s cartoon, Rugrats.
The theory behind Rugrats is that the main
characters are just a figment of Angelica's
tortured imagination.
Angelica has no emotional connection to family
so she makes up these infants to belittle
and let her anger issues out.
If that’s the case, Angelica needs to be
put in a padded room and on a well-balanced
diet of happy pills.
WALL-E
WALL-E is left on planet Earth to tidy up
the mess left by humans and he has spent the
last 700 years placing the mess into cubes.
This symbolic film about waste and the effects
on humans is a joy to watch and people easily
fall in love with the main character.
One fan theory suggests that the reason the
planet was without humans is because WALL-E
killed them all and he’s cleaning up to
repent for his sins.
This certainly would change the way we see
WALL-E but we’re pretty sure this adorable
robot didn’t do this because he can’t
even harm a bug.
Willy Wonka & the Chocolate Factory
The beloved children’s film Willy Wonka
& the Chocolate Factory has given generations
of kids the dream of visiting Wonka’s factory.
But what if those dreams turned out to be
nightmares?
Some say that Wonka is actually a cannibal
and he’s taking the bad kids and preparing
them for meals.
Augustus Gloop better hope that tube leads
to safety or he’s going to make a great
meal for Wonka, but let’s be honest.
Wouldn’t you take the chance of being eaten
to be in that candy factory?
Toy Story and Toy Story 2
In the first Toy Story film Andy can be seen
wearing a cowboy hat and then in Toy Story
2 the owner of Jessie has the same kind of
hat.
It’s theorized that Andy’s mom was the
original owner of Jessie and she passed down
her hat to her son.
If this is true, it is sad that Jessie has
lived her entire life missing Emily and when
they are reunited Emily doesn’t recognize
her.
It’s understandable for Jessie to not recognize
her because she aged but Emily seems to never
shed a tear.
Luckily Jesse finds love with Buzz and has
a new set of friends.
Wreck-It Ralph
In the film Wreck-It Ralph there’s a fictitious
arcade game called, Hero's Duty and the games
main heroine is Calhoun.
Calhoun’s husband-to-be is eaten at the
alter by a Cy-Bug and Calhoun quickly pulls
out a pocket chain gun and kills the Cy-Bug.
In the film we learn that a Cy-Bug takes the
form of whatever they eat.
When a Cy-Bug eats Ralph’s gun it takes
the form of that gun and when a Cy-Bug eats
candy it becomes candy.
So Calhoun was actually shooting the love
of her life while sporting a wedding dress.
Who Framed Roger Rabbit
Who Framed Roger Rabbit brought all of your
beloved cartoon characters in one film but
one theory suggests the plot reflects on a
dark period of American history.
This theory suggests toons are minorities
that were being oppressed by whites in a reflection
of the Jim Crow era.
They are called toons in a derogatory way,
being oppressed, kicked out of their homes
and Christopher Lloyds character tries to
assimilate to human culture but cannot making
his character an Uncle Tom.
Or it’s all about public transportation
and a voluptuous cartoon character?
Aladdin
When watching Aladdin as a kid you can’t
help but sit back and laugh at the antics
of Robin William’s Genie.
But when you grew up you might have wondered
how the Genie knew Rodney Dangerfield or Jack
Nicholson?
How does he know what a 1950’s muscle car
looks like or what an applause sign is?
One theory is that Aladdin actually takes
place in the distant future, after a horrific
nuclear war.
The Genie even complains about the accommodations
in his lamp.
Or maybe the Genie can time travel and that’s
why he’s going to Disneyland at the end
of the movie.
Either way we loved William’s jokes and
wouldn’t have it any other way.
Star Wars
Some will argue Star Wars is not a kid’s
movie but go check your shelf and count how
many Star Wars figures you have up there.
Then get back to us.
This theory suggests that the treasured characters
R2-D2 and Chewbacca are actually traitors.
R2-D2 avoids getting his memory deleted and
Chewbacca uses Han Solo as a pawn.
We’re going to stop right there because
we love those two characters and feel this
theory is traitorous and the person who thought
of it needs to meet Lord Vader.
The Incredibles
Atlas Shrugged is novel by Ayn Rand published
in 1957 about the philosophy Objectivism.
The Incredibles is about a married pair of
superhero’s who are forced to live mundane
lives after all super-powered activities have
been banned by the government.
Mr. Incredible’s talents are wasted in an
office and his son Dash is forced to never
show his super speed.
Exactly what Objectivism is against.
The main villain Syndrome wants to give everyone
the technology to be whatever they want to
be so everyone can be equal.
Once again being the essence of Objectivism.
This is a deep theory for a kids film and
all we want to know if the plot of The Incredibles
2.
There you have ten Theories That Turn Kids
Movies into Creepy Movies.
Don’t forget to subscribe to Screen Rant
for more fun videos.
Thanks for watching.